Hallo Stefan.
Hallo, alle zusammen, hallo Wolfgang.
Wir stehen vor dem Salon und ich glaube wir müssen ganz kurz sagen was der Salon
ist für die Leute die jetzt neu dazugekommen sind,
denn wir haben tatsächlich durch unsere letzte Folge sehr sehr viele neue Hörerinnen
und Hörer gewonnen und denen wollen wir nur ganz kurz sagen was wir im Salon machen.
Also im Salon, da besprechen wir die wichtigsten Texte des Monats.
Die suchen wir aus, also jeder stellt fünf Texte vor.
Und dann lesen wir immer gemeinsam ein Buch oder zwei Bücher, wie in diesem Fall.
Und das diskutieren wir dann ausführlich. Also wir werden ganz ausführlich in
diesem Salon sprechen über Triggerpunkte dazu gleich mehr und dann noch zu Hyperpolitik.
Und dann haben wir noch weitere Texte dabei.
Und diesen Salon kann man hören, wenn man ein Abo abschließt.
Das gibt es ab 2 ,50 Euro im Monat und das kann man buchen über Steady, Patreon und Apple.
Wer also diesen Podcast über Apple hört, kann dort gleich auf einen Button klicken
und kann dann dort den Salon betreten.
Wer bei Patreon schon angemeldet ist, der kann das auch da nutzen.
Wir empfehlen allerdings Steady. Dort ist dann auch ein sehr großes Archiv mit
allen Salons, die stattgefunden haben. Manchmal wird auch gefragt, wie lang ist der Salon?
In der Regel ist der Salon so zweieinhalb, drei Stunden lang.
Und ich glaube, so wird es auch heute wieder sein, denn es gibt viel zu bereden.
Sehr gutes, herausragendes Buch, das genau die Zeit, in der wir es brauchen,
erwischt hat und uns als Leser und euch als Zuhörer, von uns als Lesern,
es ist einfach ein perfekter Moment, heute in den Salon einzusteigen.
Ich glaube auch, man kann auf Grundlage dieses Buches über so viele Phänomene diskutieren.
Also man kann einfach sagen, Wagenknechtpartei wird sie erfolgreich sein und
stützt sich dabei mal nur auf dieses Buch. Man kann sich Fragen stellen der
Publizistik, wie viel Button über Wokeness soll es noch geben und stützt sich mal auf dieses Buch.
Also man kann das wirklich als eine interessante Grundlage sehen.
Ich drücke mich etwas vorsichtiger aus als du, d .h. ich habe auch Kritikpunkte,
aber die diskutieren wir dann gleich nochmal.
Aber es ist wirklich eine hochinteressante Grundlage und es ist ein Buch,
das zeigt, wie wichtig Imperie auch sein kann.
Und bevor wir aber jetzt in den Salon gleich eintreten, müssen wir eigentlich
hier noch mal so eine kleine Podcast -Folge machen über so viele verschiedene Themen.
Ich hatte schon gesagt, Twitter ist jetzt wieder wichtiger denn je.
Viele kommen zurück auf Twitter und ich sagte es und komme nach Hause und sehe,
ah, Igor Levitt, der sich auch mit viel Kampf verabschiedet hatte von Twitter,
ist jetzt auch zurückgekehrt.
Was ja für mich auch bedeutet, dass er offenbar das immer geplant hat,
denn man muss ja doch, soweit ich weiß, seinen Account immer mal wieder aktivieren.
Ach ja, alle 30 Tage, damit man nicht gelöscht wird.
Also man sieht, Twitter ist zurück.
Twitter ist zurück. Da wo man glaubt, es steppe der Bär und es werde irgendwas
entwickelt, an inhaltlichen Fragen, Antworten, was auch immer.
Ich möchte kurz zitieren aus Triggerpunkte den Buch, das wir gleich gemeinsam besprechen.
Hast du es dir auch rausgespielt?
Über alle Maßen. Schöner Satz, wir können ihn beide zitieren.
Twitter wurde aufgrund zu geringer Fallzahlen ausgeschlossen aus der Beobachtung,
wie informieren sich Menschen heute.
Das muss uns allen zu denken geben. Wir werden gleich nochmal,
also ich werde es in allerhöchstem Ton loben, warum wir diesem Buch vertrauen müssen.
Wenn wir denen nicht vertrauen, können wir gar niemandem vertrauen.
Wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt, der Steffen Mausch spinnt doch,
der schließt Twitter aus, obwohl mir das so wichtig ist.
Nein, Steffen Mauer hat recht. Bei der Beobachtung des Gemütszustand der Deutschen
spielt Twitter wirklich keine Rolle.
Ja, dieser wunderbare Satz ist also schon zitiert.
Es wird aber auch immer weniger gelesen. Das sind jetzt Zahlen,
die ein bisschen rum gingen.
Ich werde heute Amlinger, Carolin Dingsda -Bumms im Merkur.
Carolin Amlinger hat im Merkur. Ach ja, dann wirst du ja diese Zahlen präsentieren.
Du kannst sie ruhig kurz nennen.
Im Jahr 2022 haben nur noch rund 25 ,8 Millionen Menschen mindestens ein Buch gelesen.
Das sind lediglich 39 Prozent der potenziellen Käuferschaft und rund 1 ,4 Millionen
weniger Buchkäuferinnen und Buchkäufer als im Vorjahr.
In den letzten zehn Jahren ist die Buchkäuferschaft um 11 ,1 Millionen Menschen geschrumpft.
Also wer da jetzt noch sagt, man soll da aber nicht kulturpessimistisch sein
und man soll doch mal gucken, dass die Leute ja auch anderes lesen,
zum Beispiel Insta kacheln, der hat in meinen Augen nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank.
Und deswegen bin ich so froh, dass wir im Salon noch das Buch hochhalten.
Ich will kurz referieren. Ich bin gestern durch den App Store gestreift und
sehe ganz hervorgehoben Werbung für TikTok.
Ich denke mir, TikTok ist doch schon die meist runtergeladen App der Welt. Was ist denn da los?
Es wird beworben über BookTok.
Also TikTok selbst bucht Werbung im App Store bei Apple, um TikTok nochmal als
Plattform für die Intellektuellen, die Bücher lesen, vorzustellen.
Tok als Hashtag suchen oder sogar Booktok und dann das eigene Land dahinter.
Also zum Beispiel Germany, wird den Leuten nochmal gesagt. Also man macht eine
Ansprache für ganz doofe und will das aber uns allen vorgauken als TikTok ist
die App, auf der die Intellektuellen ihre Bücher besprechen.
Und das fand ich wirklich, also das irgendwo muss auch mal ein Schluss sein.
Ja, TikTok hat einen ganz großen Impact jetzt auf den Buchmarkt,
man sieht das ja daran, dass in vielen Buchhandlungen jetzt Tische stehen mit
den TikTok -Hits, also die Bücher, die dort am meisten empfohlen wurden.
Und tatsächlich ist das sehr ausschlaggebend jetzt für den Verkauf.
Wir lesen nachher in diesem Text von Amlinger, heißt sie Amlinger?
Ja, Caroline Amlinger.
Caroline Amlinger, warum man Bücher kauft.
Ja.
Ich sag noch mal so viel, Papier, Dekoration.
Es ist ein bisschen wie Tapete. Ich will nur teasern.
Ich kenne diese linke Abwehr von Bücherkäufen und hätte mich dagegen positionieren, wenn es sein muss.
Ich möchte ein anderes, ernsteres Thema aufrufen. Und zwar ist mir etwas aufgefallen.
Zum Thema ...
Nein, nicht zum Thema Buch, sondern zum Thema Nahostkonflikt.
Dann lass mich ganz kurz sagen, du hast ja gerade die Ansprache für die Leute,
die jetzt neu den Podcast hören, wie man in den Saal kommt. Ich will auch nochmal
was Allgemeines zum Podcast hier sagen.
Wir haben also durch den letzten Podcast, also sind wir an ungefähr 20 Prozent mehr Hörer.
Das heißt ja für uns immer, okay, jeder Fünfter hört das vielleicht zum ersten
Mal oder was auch immer, man hört jetzt nicht die Jahre nach.
Ich möchte sagen, ich bin auch interessiert, ob du das dann genau so siehst wie ich oder nicht.
Dieser Podcast hier ist Special Interest. Wir kriegen häufiger Mails,
in denen es heißt, Stefan, Wolfgang, super Podcast, ich bin Megafan,
ich höre seit der ersten Folge und bin noch Salon -Abonnent.
Aber ich habe jetzt meine Mutter überredet, auch mal in diesen Podcast reinzuhören.
Dann hat sie endlich reingehört und das Erste, was sie hört,
ist, dass sich Wolfgang darüber lustig macht, dass der Matze es nicht gut findet,
wenn der Kanzler nach seinen Gefühlen gefragt wird.
Und für diese Leute will ich noch mal sagen, klärt das mit eurer Mutter und nicht mit uns.
Wir werden nicht einschwenken auf diese Schiene, bei der wir sagen,
ja Gefühle sind aber auch wichtig und jeder hat seinen Lieblingspodcast und
die Nummer zwei Lieblingspodcasts in der App müssen dann Rücksicht nehmen auf die Nummer eins.
Also ja, der Matze hat recht, wenn er den Kanzler nach Gefühlen fragt. Nein, hat er nicht.
Wir besprechen das hier ausführlich. Wir können das nicht für euch über Bande
dann mit eurer Mutter klären. Ihr müsst das wirklich selber regeln.
Das hier ist ein Special -Interest -Podcast, der sich irgendwie nicht an die breite Masse richtet.
Wir haben so den Anspruch, dass man noch minimal, und jetzt schwenke ich um
auf das, was du sagen möchtest, minimal mitdenken und selbst mitfühlen.
Die also nicht in einem einstelligen Podcast eine einstellige Ansprache brauchen,
dass man in ihrem Inneren irgendwo noch Reste von Antisemitismus gefunden hat,
die jetzt rausgeprügelt werden müssen durch eine Radioansprache.
Das ist einfach der falsche Podcast dafür.
Ja, Emotionen kann man sich überall holen, aber nicht hier bei uns.
Richtig, gerade jetzt kann man sich überall holen, aber nicht bei uns.
Ja, also ich empfehle auch...
Podcastland ist voller Antisemitismus -Emotionen.
Holt sie euch ab, wenn ihr das braucht.
Oder ins Kino gehen, da gibt es auch viele Emotionen. Wie formulierte es doch
einmal Söder beim Münchner Filmfest?
Ich liebe im Kino die Anhäufung der Gefühle.
Ja, genau.
Und Anhäufung der Gefühle machen wir jetzt nicht. Und das ist perfekt als Überleitung
zu dem, was mir aufgefallen ist, nämlich zur Emotionalisierung bei Opfern.
Und zwar haben wir eine merkwürdige Opferhierarchie. Und wir haben die selbst
auch schon hier bedient, Das will ich gleich zugestehen.
Nämlich wir unterscheiden zwischen Zivilisten und Soldaten.
Und das ist ja eine Unterscheidung, die man erst mal machen muss,
um zu sagen, wer kämpft eigentlich irgendwo?
Wer ist noch auch Opfer dieser Kämpfe?
Und dann kann man natürlich dieses böse Wort Kollateralschaden in den Mund nehmen.
Also die Zivilisten sind dabei auch mit draufgegangen. Aber eigentlich ging
es um eine andere Auseinandersetzung. Aber da würde ich erst einmal festhalten
wollen, dass auch jeder Soldat ein Mensch ist.
Und möglicherweise ist dieser Soldat auch ein ideologisch manipulierter,
verblendeter, was auch immer.
Also auch Soldaten als Opfer sollten wir als Opfer anerkennen,
wenngleich ich schon für diese Unterscheidung Soldat und Zivilist bin.
Denn sonst wird alles diffus. Aber wenn wir über die Zivilisten reden,
dann machen wir auch noch mal eine Unterscheidung, Nämlich zwischen Männern, Frauen und Kindern.
Und Kinder werden jetzt ganz besonders nach vorne gestellt. Also als große Opfer
zum Beispiel jetzt in Gaza. Und da...
Möchte ich doch gewisse Zweifel anmelden.
Also Kinder sind unschuldig, weil sie unmündig sind.
Sie können nicht wählen, sie wissen noch nicht so genau, wie alles läuft.
Und sie sind da irgendwie hineingeworfen und können natürlich gar nichts für
irgendwelche geopolitischen Konflikte.
Aber ich würde auch deutlich machen wollen, dass die meisten Zivilisten ja auch nichts dafür können.
Also wenn jetzt die Bundesregierung sich von unseren Militärexperten überreden
lässt, in den Krieg zu ziehen, was man sich vorstellen könnte,
dann ist das auch nicht mein Krieg.
Also ich bin dann auch Opfer. Ich bin dann genauso Opfer wie deine Kinder.
Zwar habe ich dann ein-, zweimal gewählt und habe damit schon mal anders politischen
Willen kund getan, aber ich bin dann auch Opfer.
Das heißt, es reicht eigentlich aus zu sagen, ist sterben Zivilisten.
Man braucht diese Emotionalisierung Kinder nicht noch mal besonders.
Also die meisten Menschen sind Zivilisten und sie sind nicht verantwortlich
zu machen für das Regierungshandeln.
Wir müssen also diese Ineinsetzung von Regierungshandeln von Staat und Bürger
noch mal uns verbieten, weil wir darauf immer auch hingewiesen haben,
wenn es um die Ukraine geht.
Also die mutigen Ukrainer wollen alle kämpfen. Naja, die müssen halt.
Ich sehe das auch so. Manchmal denke ich aber in der politischen Ansprache oder
im reflektierenden Gespräch unter Journalisten, ein paar Shortcuts wären schon gut.
Und Kinder sind so ein Shortcut, denn derzeit ist ja besonders unklar,
sind in Gaza wirklich alle unschuldig, sind wirklich alle Palästinenser nicht
mit der Hamas zu unterverwechseln und was auch immer.
Und da würde ich sagen, diskutiert das gerne, aber die Hälfte dort sind Kinder
und da verbietet es sich, die als Hamas -Kämpfer einfach anzusehen.
Ich würde allerdings auch gerne sagen, grundsätzlich, also auch 20 -Jährige,
die in Gaza leben, sind halt da eingesperrt und eingezäunt und so weiter.
Wir haben ja von Lanz und so beschrieben bekommen, wie es ist,
durch so ein Grenzding mal zu treten.
Da würde ich auch sagen, dann lieber grundsätzlich nicht Volker Beck glauben.
Er wurde in die Gefechtszone definiert und deswegen sind das alles Kämpfer,
die dort anzutreffen sind, sondern nein, das sind alles Menschen.
Ja, dann werde ich heute noch einen Text vorstellen im Salon zum Ceasefire,
also zum Waffenstillstand der GmbH.
Das wird ja überraschenderweise vom Editorial Board der Financial Times kommt,
dieser Text, was doch ganz erstaunlich ist.
Aber auch da würde ich mal ganz kurz sagen wollen, ja, wir sind in einer anderen
Situation als in dem Konflikt zwischen Russland und der Ukraine.
Aber ich finde es dann doch ganz interessant. Und ich hoffe,
dass diejenigen, die jetzt den Waffenstillstand ablehnen, sich nicht so sehr
irren, wie alle, die für Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine waren.
Also zur Erinnerung, der Krieg dauert jetzt 600 Tage lang, der Frontverlauf
hat sich nicht verändert, hunderttausende sind gestorben.
Und das wurde auch dann nie mehr in den progressiven Podcasts und Sendungen thematisiert.
Ja, das ist ja einfach gar kein Thema mehr. Ukraine, da wurde jetzt ganz viel
gestorben in diesem Monat.
Das findet, man findet Berichte dazu, aber das ist nicht das Thema,
derer die sonst für Waffenlieferungen alles waren.
Und selbst wenn man mal die Zivilisten ausblendet, was man niemals tun sollte,
dann bleibt ja auch die Frage, kann man mit den jetzt von Israel angewandten
militärischen Mitteln die Hamas
besiegen? Das wäre ja die strategische Frage, die auch zu stellen ist.
Und aus der Erfahrung, 22 Jahre lang Krieg gegen den Terror,
sehen wir ja, wie wenig das funktioniert.
Und man muss jetzt natürlich sagen, und das stimmt, wird ja immer wieder eingewendet,
die Hamas verwendet Belisten als Schutzschilde.
Aber gerade wenn man das ja weiß, ist die Frage, ob man die Strategie dann der
Hamas, Menschen als Schutzschilde zu benutzen, aufgehen lässt.
Denn wir befinden uns ja auch in einem Bilderkrieg, in einem TikTok -Krieg.
Und deshalb würde ich auch da noch mal gewisse Zweifel anlegen wollen.
Also ich finde schon erstaunlich, wie dann doch manche sich so ganz bewusst
sind, was jetzt gerade zu tun ist.
Und ich würde aber auch festhalten wollen, dass ich auch gewisse Doppelstandards beobachte.
Also es gibt auch einige, die für möglichst viele Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
waren. und die auch nie die nicht vorhandenen Fluchtmöglichkeiten für ukrainische
Männer thematisiert haben.
Die aber jetzt aufs Schärfste die israelische militärische Reaktion verurteilen.
Und da wundere ich mich dann schon, warum man jetzt bei Israel sagt,
das sollen die nicht, aber hier damals war das alles okay.
Ich will mal zu diesen ...
Was du jetzt angesprochen hast, es gibt, kannte ich nicht, Tobias Huch,
hat auf Twitter 36 .000 Follower, bezeichnet sich als Journalist,
seit 16 Jahren Entwicklungs-, Not - und Flüchtlingshelfer in,
und dann kommen ein paar Flaggen, 10 Stück,
u .a. China, Ukraine, Palästina usw.
Menschenrechtsaktivist. Schreibt dann auf Twitter, die Forderung nach einem
Waffenstillstand im Krieg gegen die, Zitat, Hashtag Hamas, in Hashtag Gaza,
ist nichts anderes als Hashtag Antisemitismus.
Also Antisemitismus als Hashtag zu benutzen ist ... Da sollten wir mal grundsätzlich
darüber diskutieren, wie bei der Frage, darf man ein Konzentrationslager einfach als KZ abkürzen?
Also kann man diesen semantischen, ich sitz irgendwo rum und möchte darüber
reden, und dann sag ich einfach KZ, weil mir das Wort zu lang ist.
Also darf man sich solche Bequemlichkeiten geben.
Und wenn man sich jetzt die letzte Woche, zum Beispiel seit wir den Podcast aufgenommen haben.
Bei der Zeit oder was auch immer, an Podcasts produziert wurde zum Thema.
Man muss noch mal dieselbe Kritik anbringen, wie ich sich schon angebracht habe,
zum Beispiel auf einem Podcast vom September zu Aiwanger.
Die Journalisten benutzen Antisemitismus als Begriff wirklich nur als Hashtag.
Wie so ein Meme, dass man sich hin - und herschießt in so einer Freundesgruppe,
wo man eben schon seit Wochen keinen Text mehr geschrieben hat,
sondern nur noch, ah, hier, guck mal, ich hab ein lustiges Bild gefunden.
Und dann kommt das nächste, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Früher sprach man von, was ist eigentlich ein Facebook -Freund?
Da hat man so ein parasoziales Bild aufgemacht.
Jetzt ist es wirklich nur noch pseudosoziale Memeship.
Also, da ist von Friendship eigentlich nichts übrig. Und dieses Prinzip,
dass man sich einfach so Sachen hin und her shootet,
in der Hoffnung, dass es auf Resonanz stößt und man dann morgen so ein lustiges Bild zurückbekommt,
obwohl man ja selber jeden Tag drei Stunden durch Feeds scrollt und genug Material
hat, um sich zu begeistern oder zu belustigen und so ungefähr in diesem Kommunikationsverhalten
sind alle Journalisten gerade. Die reden zwar eine Stunde zum Thema.
Aber was jetzt Antisemitismus ist, und dass man dann auch feststellt,
beim Deutschlandfunk zum Beispiel, wir waren gestern auf der proisraelischen
Demonstration, da waren aber gar keine jungen Leute.
Da frag ich mich, wo sind denn die jungen Leute? Vielleicht muss man denen noch
mal erklären, was ist jetzt genau Antisemitismus und wo ist das Problem?
Und nicht einfach nur, ich hab jetzt Antisemitismus gesagt, damit haben jetzt
alle zehn Puls höher, sind irgendwie alarmiert, ducken sich,
niemand stellt mal eine Frage, alle hören zu.
Also diese frontale Ansprache irgendwie zum Thema Antisemitismus funktioniert einfach nicht.
Man hat doch im September gesehen, dass der Aiwanger einen Antisemitismusvorwurf
bekommt, zwei Tage lang völlig aus dem Häuschen ist, auf dem Parkplatz irgendwie
rumeilt, sich vor Journalisten versteckt und dann sich irgendwie rausredet.
Dann allerdings aufgeklärt wird von seinen Beratern, was es jetzt grundsätzlich
mit Wie machen wir Wahlkampf und so weiter auf sich hat.
Und ab Tag drei, wie ein König auftritt,
morgens freudig in die Festzelte reinrennt, wo der bayerische Wahlkampf läuft
und dort einfach eine Salve nach der anderen abfeuert, wie Trump,
der einfach alle Leute aufstellt und meinte, guckt mal hinter euch,
das sind die Journalisten, die hassen wir jetzt gemeinsam.
Also ungefähr so in diesem, in dieser Methode, in diesem Modus,
aber nicht so inhaltlich zitierfähig.
So, wir haben dann ein Wahlergebnis bekommen, das uns gezeigt hat,
wenn wir jemandem Antisemitismusvorwurf machen,
ist das reaktante Verhalten, nicht das ignorante, sondern noch eine Stufe schlimmer,
das reaktante Verhalten der Leute so, dass sie denjenigen mehr unterstützen,
mehr wählen. Er kriegt dann mehr Wählerstimmen.
So, und wie man ein Monat später, ein Monat lang, den Antisemitismusbegriff
genauso falsch wie im September verwenden kann, obwohl es noch um viel mehr
geht, verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Die Journalisten, und ich meine wirklich alle jetzt, das ist ein ganz pauschaler
Vorwurf von mir, die Journalisten, die innerhalb der großen Redaktionen,
wo sie intern rechtfertigen müssen, wie sie über welches Thema reden,
Angst schlottern, an dem Mikrofon sitzen und nach einer Stunde Gespräch,
und ich erwähne ausdrücklich die Zeit, das Politikteil, Deutschlandfunk,
diese neue Samstagsausgabe von der Tag zum Thema Nordost, Nach einstündigen
Gesprächen sich noch mal gegenseitig vor Publikum versichern,
dass sie es sehr gut fanden, dass sie jetzt darüber gesprochen haben,
obwohl sie sehr aufgeregt waren vorher. Nicht schlafen konnten.
Das geht nicht. Das ist nicht die richtige Ansprache ans Publikum. Das führt zu Reaktanz.
Das führt zu mehr antisemitischem Denken. Und vielleicht gehe ich jetzt einen
Schritt zu weit, aber an alle Journalisten, die zuhören.
Redet über das Thema ohne das Wort Antisemitismus zu benutzen.
Wenn ihr das sagen wollt, was ihr sagen wollt, dann macht lange Sätze,
kürzt es nicht ab, sagt, was ihr sagen wollt, wo das Problem ist.
Vermeidet den Hashtag Antisemitismus.
Ja, man muss den Begriff Antisemitismus verwenden, aber immer zugleich mit der
Erklärung, was damit gemeint ist und wo man aber Antisemitismus als Hashtag
verwendet, da soll es nur ein Signalwort sein.
Und das ist aber dann nur Signal, aber löst kein Denken aus.
Und ich würde mich anschließen mit der Kritik an Journalisten,
aber auch die erweiterten Politiker, die jetzt irgendwelche Dinge mal wieder
einfordern von anderen.
Wir kennen das ja schon von dem Ukraine -Krieg, wo man sagt,
ja, die wollen ja alle kämpfen.
Und wir haben jetzt auch den Fall, dass da israelische Soldaten kämpfen müssen.
Und da werden auch manche beisterben.
Und für die ist das auch furchtbar, vor allem auch dann für die Hinterbliebenen.
Und die kämpfen jetzt auch vielleicht für eine Sache, wo sie gar nicht so von
überzeugt sind. Beziehungsweise hätten sie lieber für eine andere Regierung sich hingestellt.
Und was ich hier noch mal als Ethik mitgeben würde, ist, man kann von anderen
nur etwas einfordern, sie zu etwas auffordern, wenn sie auch selbst dazu bereit sind.
Und man kann nicht von hier aus Kriege verlängern oder Waffenstillstände einfach so ausschließen.
Also wo würde man sich selbst einbringen? Bei Demonstrationen, Streiks.
Jetzt bedeutet das nicht, dass man überall zu jedem Streik eilt.
Aber grundsätzlich würde man wohl mitmachen.
Wahrscheinlich würden die meisten von uns auch kleinere Repressionen in Kauf
nehmen, die mit der Beteiligung an solchen Streiks oder Demonstrationen in Kauf zu nehmen sind.
Wie ist es denn, wenn man Beispiel zwei, also wie ist es, wenn sich da jemand
wirklich aufopfert wie Ärzte ohne Grenzen?
Kann man jemanden dazu auffordern, das zu machen, wenn man selbst dazu eigentlich
nicht bereit ist, es zwar gut findet, aber selbst dazu nicht bereit ist?
Nee, dann kann man nicht jemanden dafür auffordern. Dann kann man höchstens
den Mut der Ärzte ohne Grenzen bewundern.
Aber wenn man jetzt mal noch einen Schritt weitergeht, Wäre man selbst bereit,
sich für ein höheres Prinzip zu opfern?
Also zum Beispiel für nationalstaatliche Interessen?
Dann ist doch die Antwort 99 ,9 Prozent derer, die uns hier zuhören, nein.
Und deshalb sollten Sie auch nicht fordern, dass irgendwelche Soldaten irgendwo
reingehen, Bodenoffensive machen.
Und umgekehrt sollte man ja auch noch mal überlegen, wäre man bereit.
Selbst für ein höheres Prinzip als Kollateralschaden zu enden,
also als toter Zivilist.
Natürlich auch überhaupt nicht.
Deswegen darf man auch nicht einfach so darüber hinweggehen,
dass wahnsinnig viele Zivilisten in Gaza sterben. Und sagen,
na ja, aber so ist es halt.
Da macht man es sich ethisch so einfach oder man denkt gar nicht darüber nach.
Damit habe ich auch keinen Lösungsvorschlag zur Hand. Nur ich finde diese Leichtfertigkeit,
mit der da mal gerade über Kriege hunderte Kilometer weiter weg geredet wird.
Sehr, sehr besorgniserregend.
Ebenso besorgniserregend fand ich aber auch...
Dass wir jetzt friedliche Demonstrationen hatten und auch die für das Leid der
Palästinenser einstehen.
Und wir hatten aber auch wirklich wieder einige drastische Fälle,
die findet man ja dann doch bei Twitter ganz gut reportiert von Demonstrationen,
wo IS -Fahnen geschwungen werden, wo ich auch denke, wie kann das sein?
Also wo ist da auch die Polizei, die dort einschreitet? Werden die Fahnen nicht als solche erkannt?
Oder es gab ja dann auch so Interviews mit manchen dort, die dann gesagt haben,
ja, und die Schwulen müsste man dann auch in eine Schlucht schmeißen und so weiter.
Also das ist schon auch sehr beängstigend. Also hier würde ich auch noch mal
deutlich machen wollen, man kann jetzt nicht davor die Augen verschließen,
genauso auch vor Antisemitismus, der dort stattfindet.
Nicht grundsätzlich bei allen, die sich dort für palästinensische Rechte einsetzen,
aber es gibt dort auch einige Stimmen,
die mitunter auch Zugang zum Mikrofon haben, wo man wirklich sagen muss,
da ist nicht irgendeine progressive Idee dahinter, ganz im Gegenteil,
das ist einste Regression und Repression.
Da muss man aber auch sehen, dass, wie soll man sagen, sowas einzugrenzen,
es wird ja immer so politische Forderungen gestellt, wir brauchen mehr Verbot oder was auch immer.
Wir haben ja zum Beispiel, Nancy Faeser hat ja das Betätigungsverbot der Hamas
erwirkt hier in Deutschland, wo man sich fragt, hä, wieso war das nicht schon vorher?
Und dann stellt man fest, achso die waren vorher schon verboten.
Also es gibt sozusagen nochmal eine Stufe drauf auf das Verbot, Betätigungsverbot.
Nur irgendwo ist da eine Grenze erreicht. Also wir haben das bei G20 erlebt.
Hamburg muss abgesichert werden und ist einfach jeder deutsche Polizist in Hamburg.
Also wäre in Stuttgart eine große Terrorlage passiert, hätten wir das nicht geregelt bekommen.
Und die Ressourcen eines Staates sind wirklich sehr, sehr begrenzt.
Bei der Frage, warum findet gerade kein Krieg in Israel statt,
sondern warum ist das so contained auf Gaza?
Warum findet der Krieg in der Ukraine, nur in der Ukraine statt?
Nach so viel Zeit und so vielen Gefühlen und so weiter, die da eine Rolle spielen.
Ich habe gestern ein Interview gesehen, das mir empfohlen wurde bei Tucker Carlson.
Mit einem amerikanischen Militär, der irgendwie außer Dienst und so weiter altersbedingt.
Und da, der Typ hat aber kurz beschrieben, naja, wir können mit unseren Flugzeugträgern
bis nach Sizilien fahren.
Wenn wir näher ranfahren an die Gegend, sind wir in der Reichweite der iranischen Raketen.
Und das Problem ist, wenn wir näher ranfahren, müssen sich auch die Iraner intern
rechtfertigen, warum sie nicht einfach auf unser Boot schießen.
Also in dem Moment, wo man das zuzieht, kommen die auch im Parlament gestellten
Fragen, wie zum Beispiel, und das war ja tatsächlich gestern.
Ich habe es nur bei Twitter gelesen, ich bin gespannt, wie das im deutschen
Journalismus nochmal reflektiert wird, aber ein israelisches Regierungsmitglied
fragt öffentlich, warum man nicht einfach eine Atombombe auf Gaza schmeißt.
Wohin Netanyahu entscheidet, der Typ nimmt erstmal nicht wieder an Kabinettssitzung
teil und eine Stunde später heißt es, ja doch, er hat sich irgendwie erklärt
und jetzt darf er wieder teilnehmen.
So, also Politiker kommen dann auch in so Rechtfertigungspflichten.
Der Flugzeugträger ist doch da, warum bombardieren wir den nicht?
Hat der Iran die Hisbollah so unter Kontrolle, dass er ausschließen kann,
dass die Hisbollah -Leute tatsächlich den Flugzeugträger bombardieren?
Man weiß es ja alles nicht.
Also fahren die erst mal nicht nah ran und der Iran hält auch die Füße still
und dann kommt irgendwie diese große Ansprache der iranischen Regierung,
wo es dann heißt, naja, wir verstehen das jetzt erst mal nicht,
als wir sollten in den Krieg ziehen und so weiter.
Und man hört es dann so und ist so ein bisschen erleichtert und denkt sich,
nee, die wissen einfach selber, dass ihre Ressourcen sehr beschränkt sind und
dass sie, wenn der Krieg einmal läuft, auch nicht wissen, wie es dann weitergeht.
Sondern dann greift das Kameradschaftsprinzip, also dann stehe ich in der Pflicht,
das Land zu verteidigen.
Und das versuchen gerade alle zu vermeiden. Wir sagen dann so ein bisschen,
ja, das ist blinkens ganz erfolgreiche Diplomatie.
Ist es auch, hat aber mit diesen Ressourcensachen zu tun. Und diese Ressourcenfragen
werden gerade komplett ausgeblendet.
Weil man könnte ja auch einfach, wenn man feststellt, Antisemitismus ist ein
inhaltliches Problem, sagen, ja, dann sollten wir das mal an der Wurzel packen.
Ja, wo ist denn die Wurzel?
Also, wenn jemand mit einer IS -Fahne über eine deutsche Straße zieht,
dann ist das nicht Wurzel, sondern dann ist der Baum schon aufgeblüht in der
Frühlingsblüte und dann kann man
vielleicht nochmal mit einem Leiterwagen hochfahren und die Blüten zupfen.
Nein, wir müssen natürlich in alle deutschen Schulen, Ausgehend von Grundschulen,
das sind alleine in Frankfurt 70, 75 müsste man einfach ein politisches Bildungsprogramm mitfahren.
Und wenn man feststellt, ach dafür haben wir gar keine Lehrer,
ok, dann brauchen wir jetzt Lehrer dafür. Für jede Schule mindestens eine,
damit jede Klasse einmal pro Woche so einen thematischen Unterricht bekommen kann.
Krass, das sind ja in Frankfurt alleine schon 75 Leute.
Dann muss man halt dann reingehen. Aber einfach am Ende eines nicht gegangenen
Weges plötzlich festzustellen, die es Flaggen auf deutschen Straßen und dann
eine politische Antwort formulieren, schwierig.
Da ist einfach vorher so viel verschlafen und verpennt worden.
Dann hat man es wirklich nur noch mit Fleischhauer Tweets zu tun,
mit denen man sich dann rumschlagen kann, aber die führen alle zu nichts.
Also nein, der wird ja auch nicht auf die Idee kommen, mehr Lehrer einzustellen,
damit man besseren Geschichtsunterricht hat, damit auch junge Leute mal wissen,
was Antisemitismus ist.
Nun kommen wir noch zu einem anderen Diskurs -Dilemma, das ich schon auch während
Corona beobachtet habe und dann jetzt nochmal aufgetaucht ist mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine,
jetzt beim Nordkonflikt und zwar die Konjunktion aber.
Also es gibt so eine Verunglimpfung des Abers und das finde ich doch ganz interessant.
Wir hatten ja diesen Auszug von Adorno aus den minima moralia,
wo er sagt, also dieses, wer nicht für mich ist, ist wieder mich, das ist Sal Schmidt.
Und das ist eigentlich die Grundlage schon für Antisemitismus.
Also Adorno sagt, man kommt eigentlich bei einem ganz manichärischen Weltbild
an, wenn man nur noch tätische Sätze zulässt.
Karl Schmitt konnte diese tätischen Sätze sehr gut formulieren.
Aber wenn man jetzt dahin gelangt, dass man die Konjunktion aber eigentlich verunklimpfen muss.
Wenn man sagt, alles, was vor dem Aber gesagt wird, zählt nicht.
Das ist der Vorwurf, der bei Twitter immer gemacht wird, wenn sie was formulieren.
Ich bin für die Corona -Maßnahmen, aber ich ziehe in Zweifel,
dass wir die Schulen dauerhaft schließen sollten, dann wird so getan,
als sei das Aber, würde das davorgesagte negieren.
Und zunächst einmal muss man ja feststellen, mit dieser Konjunktion verbindet man.
Zwei Sätze und man schränkt damit die Aussage des ersten Satzes etwas ein.
Aber das hat ja auch etwas Verbindendes beziehungsweise kann man auch so einen Gegensatz klar machen.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal beim Gegensatz bleiben, dann müssen wir erst mal feststellen,
dass ohne das Hineinbringen von Gegensätzen, also ohne das Aber,
jedes dialektische Denken entfällt.
Wer sich also des Abers entledigt, will nicht mehr dialektisch über etwas nachdenken.
Ja, oder wir sagen einfach gar nicht mehr nachdenken. Ich würde selbst dialektisch noch streichen.
Oder gar nicht mehr. Und auch bei Einschränkungen, die ja das Aber vollziehen
kann, ist es ja wichtig, dass wir Einschränkungen haben.
Also was, ich hatte das im Podcast davor schon gesagt, was ist eigentlich uneingeschränkt bei uns?
Weil ja auch von uneingeschränkter Solidarität oder so etwas gesprochen wird.
Na, man macht immer Einschränkungen. Also ich fahre bekanntermaßen gerne Auto,
aber ich weiß, das ist schlecht für die Umwelt.
Und daraus, aus diesem Aber ziehe ich ja dann gewisse Schlussfolgerungen,
dass ich jetzt nicht ein Auto kaufen würde, das zwölf Liter verbraucht.
Oder man sagt, ich liebe XY, aber XY darf mich nicht betrügen.
Also die Liebe ist auch an Bedingungen geknüpft, die das Aber macht.
Also wenn man nur noch eine Welt aufbauen will ohne Abas, dann kann man nur
noch ganz simple naturwissenschaftliche Aussagen treffen.
Zwei plus zwei ist vier. Da gibt's kein Aber.
Selbst das ist ja umstritten.
Ja, bei der Poincaré -Vermutung, wir wissen, dass bei der höheren Mathematik
da kann auch der Kreis ein Dreieck sein und umgekehrt.
Nur dieses Aber, dass man dieses abschaffen will, das erinnert mich eigentlich,
und da sind wir schon fast hier bei unserem Buch Trägerpunkte, an religiöses Denken.
Mir fiel dann auf, wo gibt es eigentlich kein Aber? Zum Beispiel im Glaubensbekenntnis.
Also das Glaubensbekenntnis des Christliches geht los mit, ich glaube an Gott,
den Vater, den Allmächtigen, den Schöpfer des Himmels und der Erde.
Und an Jesus Christus, seinen eingeborenen Sohn, seinen Herrn,
empfangen, unseren Herrn empfangen durch den Heiligen Geist,
geboren von der Jungfrau Maria. Das ist alles ohne Aber.
Aber wenn das so und so ist, dann ist er doch nicht allmächtig oder so. Es ist alles ohne Aber.
Und wir können daran an diesem Aber -Verbot eigentlich schon sehen,
dass wir in so einer Zeit des Tribalismus leben.
Also das ist so ein religiöser Diskurs, der dann wiederkommt und man kann sich
nur noch auf die eine oder die andere Seite schlagen.
Und deswegen würde ich auch da noch mal plädieren für eine Differenzierung. Es gibt.
Abers, die berechtigt sind, und Abers, die nicht berechtigt sind.
Ich habe mir zwei Beispiele aufgeschrieben, um das klarzumachen.
Und zwar kann ich ein Aber formulieren, das so geht.
Der Hamas -Anschlag war schlimm, aber Israel ist selbst schuld.
Das ist ein falsches Aber, ein undurchdachtes Aber, ein israelfeindliches Aber.
Jetzt komme ich mit einem anderen Aber. Israel hat das Recht,
sich zu verteidigen, Aber Israel muss dabei das Völkerrecht beachten.
Das ist in meinen Augen ein sehr kluges Aber, dass er auch beiden ganz am Anfang
schon in seinen Äußerungen so getätigt hat.
Und deswegen das Aber per se abzulehnen, ist wirklich das dümmste, was man machen kann.
Ja, ich bin auch total für Aberismus, weil das Gegenteil ist ja intellektueller Absolutismus.
Oder anders formuliert nach Harari diese Faulheit, vor der er uns warnte,
dass wir einfach die Sätze, die uns so vorgelegt werden, einfach übernehmen.
Das machen wir nicht. Und bei Triggerpunkte ist ja ganz interessant,
Steffen Maust ist ja so wichtig, dass man fast denkt, er hätte noch darüber
nachgedacht, das Buch einfach Ja -Aber -Gesellschaft, die Ja -Aber -Gesellschaft zu nennen.
Ja.
Gut, also damit gehen wir gleich in den Salon. Ich möchte unbedingt noch den
Kragen rehabilitieren.
Er ist auch in Verruf gekommen zuletzt, wie ihr mitbekommen habt.
Nein, das müssen wir kurz erklären, das haben nicht alle mitbekommen.
Viele Seligen sind ja auch nicht bei Twitter und sonst wo halt so.
Greta Thunberg hat sich ja mehrmals geäußert zum Thema Nahostkonflikt.
Und die ist dort auf der palästinensischen Seite, um es möglichst vorsichtig auszudrücken.
Ich würde aber ihr ganz klar vorwerfen, dass sie Doppelstandards anlegt und
dass sie auch dazu geschwiegen hat, was die Hamas angerichtet hat in Israel.
Ich finde das eine sehr, sehr fürchterliche Tendenz.
Und will noch auch dazu sagen, Greta Thunberg war diejenige gewesen,
die ein Aber -Verbot auch erteilt hat durch eine spezielle Formulierung im Ukraine -Krieg.
Sie sprach nämlich immer vom unprovozierten Angriffskrieg Russlands.
Und dieses Unprovoziert, also man kann natürlich darüber schreiten,
was ist eine Provokation und was nicht.
Und ich würde auch nicht sagen, ja Putin musste das so machen,
aber indem man gleich sagt Unprovoziert, tut man also so, als sei dieser Krieg
aus dem Nichts gekommen und sei dann einfach da.
Und damit hat sie auch so ein Diskursverbot verhängt. Und jetzt kommt sie aber
mit so einem riesigen Aber und formuliert das als erstes, bevor sie das andere überhaupt genannt hat.
Sie sagt eigentlich sofort Aber mit Aber die Palästinenser. Und nun war es so,
dass sie ein entsprechendes Foto gepostet hatte mit drei anderen Aktivisten.
Da stand dann Free Palestine und so weiter auf den kleinen Schildchen,
die sie gebastelt hatten.
Und dieses Foto ging rum und dann fiel schnell Leuten auf, dass es dort neben
Greta Thunberg auf dem Sofa ein Kuscheltier gibt.
Und man hat dann darin antisemitische Symbolik gesehen.
Und jetzt bist du dran. Was war das?
Also, ganz rechts im Bild, bevor sie es abgeschnitten hatte.
Sagen wir es mal so, ich kannte den antisemitischen Oktopus,
weil ich schon mal diese Wahlenplakate gesehen habe.
Damals war es direkt die NSDAP oder irgendein Super -PAC oder keine Ahnung,
jedenfalls die Krake, die die Welt umschlingt. und so weiter.
Und dann tauchte der bei Greta als kleine Kuscheltierkrake in diesem Bild mit auf.
Und dann hieß es plötzlich, nee, das ist für sie als im Spektrum des Autismus,
genau, irgendwo verortet ein Tier, das ihr hilft über Emotionen zu sprechen.
Und da hab ich gedacht, was ist denn das für ein komisches Konzept?
Ich laufe durch meine Wohnung und sehe plötzlich nur noch diese Kraken überall.
Ach.
Selbst bei meinem Teenager -Töchterchen auf dem Bett. Und denke mir,
krass, die sind ja echt überall, was hat es denn damit auf sich?
Also stelle ich fest, okay, dieser Krake hat offenbar nicht nur eine antisemitische
Dimension, sondern im Beisein einer Autistin irgendwie doch erwartbar.
Und zwar auch genau so, liegt halt einfach oben, weil sie so bei sich ist.
Man hat nicht über die Bildlogik nachgedacht.
Ja, sie ist ja da in so einer sozialen Konstellation, das von ihrem Bild gemacht
wird, von dem sie weiß, das wird gleich in die ganze Welt geliefert und so.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Was auch immer, sie ist als Autistin unter Leuten, also hat sie natürlich ihre Krake dabei.
Also liegt die auch genauso im Bild, nur wenn man das Bild einfach so sieht,
denkt man, krass, die hat das aber wirklich noch vor einer Sekunde in der Hand
gehabt und hat es dann einfach dahin gelegt. So ungefähr.
Also in der Hinsicht, ich will jetzt nicht einsteigen da, aber...
Man unterstellte ihr, es sei platziert und sie wollte damit eine besondere Symbole
tragen und das hat sie negiert.
Genau, und sie hat das Bild dann nochmal neu zugeschnitten und wieder gepostet
und da war dann diese Armlinie da, von dieser zu sehen.
Also den Vorwurf würde ich ja auch nicht machen.
Genau, interessanterweise ist es dann so, dass ich feststelle,
nee, das ist tatsächlich dieser Emotionskrake, also den stirbt man einfach um.
Der hat gute und schlechte Laune und dann muss das Kind nicht reden,
sondern das stirbt den einfach um.
Also je nachdem, welche Seite oben ist, ist es dann, nee, ich bin gerade schlecht gelaunt und so, ne?
Und das Kind markiert dann einfach, wie die eigene Stimmungslage so ist.
Und dann höre ich allerdings die politischen Podcasts, in dem Falle Micky Beisenherz
Podcast, der ja nicht zu unterschätzen ist, weil den wirklich alle in Deutschland hören.
Also das ist wirklich der neue Deutschlandfunk.
Morgens hören alle hier Filterkaffee und Apokalypse oder Apokalypse und Filterkaffee.
Und da greifen die beiden, und in dem Falle Micky Beisenherz und seine Freundin
oder Frau Niki Hassania, auch den Kraken auf und zwar für mich total überraschend
aus genau der anderen Richtung als ich.
Eine Kuschelkrake. Der Krake aus Stoff, der da so im Hintergrund war.
Und dann haben viele Leute gesagt, aha, das ist ein Code.
Denn der Krake, der ist ein Symbol, das ist eine eine Chiffre,
eine antisemitische Symbolik.
Denn schon die Nationalsozialisten nutzten die Krake als Symbol der vermeintlichen
jüdischen Weltverschwörung, die mit ihren Tentakeln die ganze Welt umschließt.
Ich zitiere an dieser Stelle.
Ich habs nicht gewusst, muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen. Was?
Ich wusste es auch nicht. Schrecklicher Verdacht war Krake Paul Antisemit und
wir haben unsere Fußballergebnisse eben.
Also deshalb war mir nicht bewusst. Ich meine diese Kraken Plüschtiere sind
ja echt im Trend. Wir haben doch zu Hause auch eins. Wir haben auch eins.
Das ist echt süß. Und deshalb ich...
So, also die beiden kannten das auch nicht als antisemitische Symbol.
Ich habe mich dunkel dran erinnert. Ah ja, da war mir was.
Im Bild ist es mir auch nicht aufgefallen.
Es gab ja auch so Zuckerberg Karikaturen mal, die in diese Richtung gehen.
Ja, irgendwie so. Also so und jetzt ist mir aber ganz wichtig,
dass wir den Kraken mal entschuldigen und zwar oder rehabilitieren.
Der Kraken kann ja nichts dafür, es ist ja nur unser Gespräch über den Kraken.
Wir müssen den Kraken rehabilitieren und zwar mit Hilfe von Aussagen Richard David Precht.
Jetzt denken alle, er hat sich jetzt auch schon wieder dazu geäußert.
Nein, dieser Clip ist Monate alt, also der war weit vor dem 7.
Oktober aufgenommen, Podcast 106 von Precht und Lanz.
Richard David Precht macht mal eine Anmerkung über den Kraken,
die wir jetzt einfach für uns mal in unsere Zeit so inkorporieren.
Diese Tragik, die über dem Krakenleben lebt, dass der Krake vielleicht nicht
empfindet, aber die ich empfinde.
Sie werden nicht alt. Wie alt werden die? Ich glaube sie sind so zwei oder zweieinhalb Jahre.
Das ist gar nichts. Zu viel Sex, eindeutig. Vielleicht ist das der Grund.
Energieverschwendung. Warum? Kraken haben keine kulturelle Evolution.
Sie haben keine lange Zeit, ihren Kindern viel beizubringen.
Und das ist der ganz große Vorteil, den der Mensch hat. Der Trager hat eindeutig
die besseren Anlagen als der Mensch.
So dolle ist das nicht, da auf den Bäumen rumzuhüpfen und ein bisschen mehr
nach vorne sehen können, als zur Seite sehen können.
Im Grunde genommen von der Ausstattung her übertreiben wir ja immer,
dass wir sagen, was wir für Meisterwerke der Schutzfunk sind.
Die menschliche Hand, was die alles kann und was weiß ich was.
Also können die von 400 anderen Primatenarten auch, ja, und mit der Hand sind
auch viele andere Tiere sehr geschickt.
Der Kraker hat ja die mit Abstand besten Voraussetzungen. Aber was soll man
tun, wenn er wie alle Genies früh stirbt?
Sehr schön. Jetzt können wir aber überlegen, spielen wir diesen Vorteil eigentlich
gerade aus gegenüber dem Kraken? Oder ist für uns einfach immer Tag 1?
Haben wir gar keinen Vorteil davon, dass wir uns an Sachen erinnern,
die vielleicht schon mal nicht funktioniert haben? Aus der Geschichte lernen,
Kinder sozialisieren oder ignorieren wir das alles gerade und verhalten uns wie Kraken.
Ich denke, die Antwort kann jeder selbst geben. Sehr gut.
Jeder macht jetzt bitte einfach die Krakenreflexion. Bin ich eigentlich gerade auf Krakenniveau?
Zwei Jahre alt oder älter. Kann ich noch den Kindern was mitgeben.
Gut, wir wollen in den Salon geben, wollen dort auch bekannt geben,
zu welchen Terminen man uns live erleben kann in Frankfurt und wie man dann an die Tickets kommt.
Wir lesen also Triggerpunkte, Konsens und Konflikt in der Gegenwartsgesellschaft.
Außerdem Hyperpolitik von Anton Jäger.
Und ich habe mir das Techno -Optimist -Manifesto durchgelesen von Marc Andreessen.
Ein libertäres Manifest, das es verdient ein bisschen besprochen zu werden zumindest.
Dann wie schon gesagt das Ceasefire -Pleduier aus der Financial Times.
Dann ein sehr interessanter Text für mich, Der Text, der mich am meisten inspiriert
hat zu dem Nahostkonflikt, nämlich da fordert Noah Smith eine Drei -Staaten -Lösung.
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt sage, das ist jetzt mein Prinzip, so müssen wir vorgehen.
Ich fand aber den Text hochinteressant, welche Richtung er ging.
Dann möchte ich jemanden canceln, und zwar Ricarda Lang.
Sie hat gemeinsam mit Winfried Kretschmer einen Text geschrieben,
wie wir jetzt mit Migranten umgehen sollen.
Und ich will mal so sagen, hätte denen Sarah Wagenknecht geschrieben, wäre der Teufel los.
Aber offenbar geht das alles so durch.
Also Kretschmann und Lang schreiben im Tagesspiegel darüber.
Ja, das sind so die Sachen, die ich vorhabe.
Okay, also Caroline Amlinger hat im November Merkur über das Lesen,
die Lesekrise geschrieben.
Es ist nicht, ja, es ist auf der einen Art diese Standard, es ist Buchmessenzeit,
also beklagen wir noch mal den Untergang des Buches, aber das sind doch so ein
paar Anmerkungen auch zum Thema, wie gehen wir eigentlich mit Papier, Büchern gerade um.
Dann die New York Times über Donald Trumps Wahlkampf.
Wir wissen alle noch, wie Donald Trump damals kritisiert und belächelt hat, dass...
Es sind ja alle Stimmen geklaut worden, weil die Demokraten so Delegiertensysteme
hatten, die eigentlich nur eine Favoritenrolle vorsahen, nämlich Hillary Clinton.
Davon hat Trump sehr gelernt, wie man so was macht. Und zwar in jedem einzelnen amerikanischen Staat.
Und wir werden in der Zeit das Virus in den Köpfen.
Dieser Text ist gerade so eine Rubrikenüberschrift, Aufarbeitung der Corona -Pandemie.
Wir gehen mal sehr kritisch durch, was die Journalisten meinen,
was jetzt als Aufarbeitung zu gelten habe, ob ihnen das gelungen ist oder nicht
und welche Fragen da noch so mitschwingt.
Und ich will noch ein Buch dann vorstellen, das ist mir gerade eingefallen,
hier lag es unter den Zetteln, von Iris Murdoch, Die Souveränität des Guten,
eine amerikanische Philosophin, die gerade jetzt wiederentdeckt wird.
Das also ist alles im Salon zu erleben, über Steady, Patreon oder Apple sind wir dort erreichbar.
Wer den Salon nicht hören möchte, uns aber trotzdem unterstützen möchte,
kann auch so den Salon buchen und wir freuen uns dann auf gleich.
Bis gleich.